after weeks of intense fighting
resulting in battered equipment and
logistical issues in the capital of kiev
and other northern cities russian forces
changed
the donbass region with flat countryside
terrain is a more familiar battleground
for russia's military which has trained
a large portion of its forces in
open-air combat
and its landscape is more suited to
conventional battles involving artillery
systems moscow is estimated to have
thousands of tanks already deployed in
the region where russian-led separatists
have been waging war since 2014. to a
large degree it is tank country that is
you can really conduct mechanized
warfare operations that is really
the types of operations that the russian
armed forces traditionally are quite
good at the move comes after russian
forces faced several setbacks in cities
across the country among the key issues
failing to establish dominance in the
skies and not preparing for stiff
resistance from ukrainian fighters
military experts say
so as russia shifts its approach to
focus on the east we analyze what went
wrong for moscow and kiev and why it
believes it can succeed in this next
phase of war
these images show a convoy of russian
tanks infantry fighting vehicles
self-propelled artillery and logistical
support heading toward kiev in late
february the column was thwarted by
ukrainian resistance efforts just days
after moscow began its invasion of its
smaller neighbor part of russia's
biggest failure to take key was that it
stuck to the roads as military analysts
say
we saw satellite imagery showed us these
large columns long columns of tanks and
armored vehicles
going for kilometers and miles on these
roads and ukraine did a really good job
of ambushing them from the forests and
from the sky with drones striking the
long supply lines created logistical
problems for russia as it tried to
support its forces inside the country
russian forces at the front were
struggling to get basic things like even
food and water let alone equipment early
russian advances to take control of the
capital and other northern cities were
also hampered by poor tactics according
to analysts they haven't really trained
for it on a large scale
the russian armed forces are
essentially an artillery army supported
by mechanized forces that is tanks and
other armored vehicles
so they always were short on infantry
because the way they fight they're not
really meant to go into cities and
conduct urban combat operations that
paired with an unexpectedly resolute
defense from the ukrainian forces armed
with nimbler weapons including
turkish-made armed drones and us-made
javelins left russia vulnerable in the
city and saw their forces retreat in
late march
russian officials have pushed back
against western and ukrainian claims
that it has failed i don't think we
failed frankly we conduct our military
operation it's not a war it's a military
operation it has its own uh strategy
it's called it has its own aims russia's
defense ministry didn't immediately
respond to requests for comment about
their changing strategy in kiev and the
dunbas region
following failures to take kiev russia
refocused its strategy to try to take
control of the donbass region
russia has been fighting a conflict for
eight years there already pro-russian
separatists broke away in two parts of
the east
donetsk and lugansk back in 2014 after
russia seized crimea from ukraine
military analysts say controlling the
region and mariupol could be key for
connecting what they describe as a land
bridge between the south of ukraine and
russia
uniting the eastern and southern front
lines of russian forces i think it would
make it easier also to resupply
the russian russian troops in the south
there are also environmental factors at
play in contrast to key where dense
urban wooded areas prove difficult for
russian forces the donbass region is
more open which some analysts compare to
a world war ii battlefield if it can
coordinate its forces that could allow
russia to leverage its military
equipment the situation is a bit more
advantageous for the russian armed
forces but of course there are also some
deficits and the russians are running
low on precision guided munitions and
moscow faces a protracted fight with
thousands of battle-hardened forces in
the region analysts say ukraine is
believed to have between 40 and 50 000
soldiers in the donbas many of whom have
spent years fighting against
russian-backed separatists
but a big factor in who can control this
next phase of war analysts say is who
can achieve air superiority a key detail
that has so far been hard for open
source investigators to track you really
would want to dominate
the skies above your troops as they're
advancing make sure that no enemy
aircraft can attack your troops making
sure that no enemy missiles can hit your
troops for ukraine to be able to
withstand such attacks from russia in
the east keeping the flow of advanced
weapons from the us and other countries
is key analysts say ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky has demanded continued
assistance from allies as the country
enters a different stage of war
but despite russia's shifting military
focus putin's initial ambitions which
western officials said were to take the
capital and install a new government may
remain the same
[Music]